good afternoon cs19 how are you guys
doing
today okay I appreciate that I know that
there for many people there is still a
midterm tonight um hey I just want to
say thanks for coming I really
appreciate in fact actually there's bets
going on in the Tas about like how many
people would actually be able to come
today and we thought like do we cancel
lecture we're like no this is the best
lecture we can't cancel it um and we
were all underestimated uh there is a
small note I didn't want to say there's
no word of the day for for today
everyone's going to get credit um but
this is one of the more core lectures so
if you're watching it you are doing such
a good favor to your future self this is
one of my favorite lectures in cs19 and
if you're watching this online
definitely something going to want to
know and certainly need to know for your
problem set coming up
um we are going to be doing the most
beautiful meta thing we're going to be
think about the random variable of
probabilities and there probably
couldn't be a more CS 109 topic it's so
deep and it's so profound and it solves
real life problems you probably have
this intuition I present you with two
YouTube videos and forget about the
content though if you're not into Dave
504 yet you should check it out he's a
slapping bass player uh and if you saw
these two YouTube videos and you're just
thinking about um the probability that
you'll like the movie and you just look
at number of
likes this one has 10,000 likes and 50
dislikes this one has 10 likes and zero
dislikes if you were sorting by you know
a probability of a like you might decide
that this has a one probability of like
and this doesn't and you might get kind
of the erroneous result that this might
be the movie that you're more likely to
like does that make sense intuitively do
you guys get the idea that this is
probably a better choice if you had to
just choose one based off of likes but
wouldn't it be nice to put some real
fundamental mathematics behind that
we're going to do that today we going to
learn the most cool thing it's such good
practice for you it's going to solve
problems like this and it's also going
to be a foundation upon which we're
going to build all these beautiful
randomized
algorithms so I presented one problem
for you guys how do you choose your
YouTube video but there's lots of
problems that I could tell you that we
don't have a good fundamental
perspective on which we're going to get
today and here's another issue that I
could talk about here are two different
people who give you a probability of8
for whether or not it's going to rain
tomorrow one person just says uh I don't
know my leg itches went rain so I'm
going to say there's an 80% chance of
rains tomorrow and somebody's like I've
done some hardcore calculations I've
seen a whole bunch of information in the
past and based on that I have a
probability point8 tomorrow until now in
CS 109 both of these are treated the
same they're both treated as probability
of 08 but Okay who wants to go with Pro
person a who thinks that like they're
the more reasonable person to trust and
who thinks person B yeah person B we
don't have a language for how confident
somebody should be and that's not so bad
if you're choosing between 08 and8 but
it does become a problem if you have to
get more information and update a belief
like now if we gather something like the
weather of the day before then maybe
when we have to incorporate our new
information we have to think about
confidence in a more interesting way
okay so I'm presenting some things that
we should be able to do but we can't do
and then I'm going to leave you with
this philosophy this is one of the deep
philosophies of cs19 those who are able
to represent what they do not know make
better
decisions if you think about it you know
we take all these Concepts that you
might have thought of as single numbers
and we turn them into whole belief
distributions we've been doing that for
a while in CS 109 and we're going to
take that to the next level today and
today we're going to think about
representing what we do not know about
probabilities themselves okay so it's
going to be a little bit unintuitive but
the math is deeply beautiful and it is
incredibly useful also did want to note
that problem set four is out it's got a
whole bunch of cool things like you're
going to be working with real Bean
networks um you are going to be
expressing uncertainty as to somebody's
ability uh I think this one was for
chess uh you're going to be looking at
biometric creas Strokes there's a whole
bunch of really wonderful interesting
problems and one of the interesting ones
we're going to play today so I won't get
too much into it now but you're going to
be thinking about learning while helping
if you have to make a choice between a
and b and you have to dynamically make
that choice while that choice is also
affect in people how do you do that in a
good
way in the problem set the first chunk
of it has to do with problemistic models
and the last chunk of it is from today's
lecture so learn today's lecture and
then you'll finish off with the
knowledge you'll need for problem set
4 not too much review we're going to
build off of but if there's one concept
we're really going to build off of is
this idea of inference you have a prior
belief you get an observation and then
you update your belief and the reason
that this is so interesting is this was
modeling somebody's ability to see
before 109 came to this test people
would think about ability to see as a
single number and then we turned it into
a whole random variable with a whole
probability distribution instead of
thinking ability to see a single number
we say okay there's some possibility
this person really can't see and some
possibility they really can see and I'm
going to have a belief for every
possible assignment to how well they can
see and that's how I represent ability
to see not just one number a whole
random variable questions about that
before I jump in two
things okay that's what we're building
off of um oh and just you know when we
got into this problem uh don't forget
that we really solved this problem by
having base theorem you took your random
variable and then when you got more
information you could use a function of
How likely you were to see your
observations given the true state of
somebody's ability to see you could use
base theorem and you could update your
random variables belief so not only is
it more expressive to use a whole random
variable but we also have this wonderful
language for how to incorporate
information to update our
beliefs okay and then um in plain
English the things you needed for Bas
theorem was a prior belief you need a
likelihood function How likely is an
observation given a state of a random
variable uh and then one of the things
we've talked a lot about is ways you can
deal with this denominator we called
this the normalization constant and
we've talked about how actually because
this denominator is not changing as
values of little a changes one way to
think about this is this is a
constant and if you solve this numerator
for all the different values of little a
like I calculate this for little a
equals Zer I Cal this numerator for
little a equal 0.1 if you calculate all
those values for all the little A's if
you sum them up that's what this is so
you can calculate all your values of the
numerator and then just normalize and
that's a quick way to do B theorem over
a whole random variable end of review
shall we jump into the mystery that is
today and I did want to let you know
where we are we've getting so close
we're on this last penultimate section
of class where we're learning about
uncertainty Theory we're going to start
diving deeper into the underpinning
mathematics of probability
Theory okay and it starts with flipping
a
plate I'm going to be taking this plate
here I'm going to start flipping this
plate in fact I'm going to play a game
I'm going to ask for a volunteer to come
join it and while somebody's thinking
about whether or not they want to play
I'm going to let you know that I want a
dividual for the slide so I asked uh AI
agent Dolly to come up with a rem Branch
version of me flipping a a plate in
class so AI drew that painting anyone
want to come play this game yeah come on
up you raise your hand first yeah yeah
so you get to come um and this game is
very simple you're going to flip a plate
three times and if you get head three
times uh you win and then we'll discuss
what your prize is so you've only got
like a 30% chance of winning but you
know like you cost cost you nothing to
play from side this is Heads This is
Tails does that count it's a plate it
doesn't have heads and tails what are we
talking about question real quick yes
did you type Chris Peach into Dolly no I
[Laughter]
wish okay we got one tails and zero
heads okay who who whoa whoa whoa whoa
slow down tails and
heads one Tails okay we got four more
flips to go
two
tails okay we need three heads row do it
you can do
it yes okay two more
heads whoa it comes down to the final
flip okay Round of Applause we got this
you can do it
yay okay now we have to discuss Sur
prize well come come talk to me after
class and we'll figure out what that
is round of applause thank you very much
wonderful in class we know how to think
about you know this binomial
distribution every time you flip a coin
or you you run an experiment it's
independent and we think it's got equal
probability of being heads uh
now there's just this one assumption
that really I want to Pro make
problematic which is if you have a coin
there's an argument why heads and tails
should be equal it's symmetric you know
there's no reason head should be more
likely than another but with my plate
it's not
symmetric so you lose your ability to
say there's a 50% chance of heads and a
50% chance of Tails um and and really I
want to leave you with this question
what is the probability of heads on this
plate cuz all of our analysis is based
off of us knowing it's 1/2 but we don't
know it's 1/2 and how could we think
about that now plates are not that
interesting you know what is interesting
drugs people coming up with drugs want
to decide wow somebody is going to cut
that Cliff uh and it's going to come
across
wrong uh I meant medical drugs uh and so
if you give a a medical drug to somebody
you want to know the probability that it
solves their
problem and that's not going to be
50/50 but knowing that's going to be
really important and you're often going
to be estimating it really quickly when
you have not that much data you might
have tried it on six people you need to
really quickly figure out what is its
probability
so it leads to this final question that
I want to PL to your mind what's your
belief that a coin flip gives you
heads and on some level that's asking
the question is think about
p and I want to start thinking about it
as a random
variable so the number of heads that was
a binomial but that P for the binomial
that's the probity of getting heads on
the coin flip I want to do the wildest
thing and we're going to take this wild
leap and it's going to take us on such
an adventure and the wild leap I've
written on the board and I'm actually
going to try and do some board work
today I'm going to allow the probability
of heads to be a random variable itself
let me show you you know random
variables we think of them as being
represented by a probably Mass function
or probably density
function if x is a random variable it
means it can take on any value between
zero and one agreed why not more than
one cuz it's represent a probability I
want to think about X as a random
variable so I might get a probability
Mass
function like that and if I had a
probability or probably density function
rather like that it would be saying that
I think the probability is somewhere
between like 50% and 60% or maybe like
30% and
60% so we're going to try and come up
with a way of thinking about X as a
random variable which means we're going
to really want to try and come up with a
probability density function for
x now I'm going to give you a particular
context to think about and the
particular context to think about is
I've flipped this plate 10 times and I
flipped this plate 10 times and I got
nine heads and if I got nine heads this
would be a pretty reasonable estimate
for the probability wouldn't it
be but that single number is not a
random variable it's just a number and
it's missing the expressivity of saying
I got this number from only only 10
flips you know that 90% would have been
the same number you gotten if you had
100,000 flips and you know uh 90,000 of
those came up as heads and they should
have different
confidences so I'm going to break all of
the logic we've had so far and I'm going
to let X be your random variable we're
no longer having probability being a
number it's going to be a random
variable why don't I use capital P for
the random variable for
probability wouldn't that be so awful
it' be like P of P equals x oh my God my
notation would be awful so I want to
have a random variable for probability
I'm going to use x because I can't use
capital P in probability
land
okay if I make x a random variable I
have a different way of thinking about
probability if I've seen nine heads and
one Tails I can write this beautiful
equation which you've never seen before
but it's a really cool one it's saying
what's my belief in
probability given I've seen nine heads
and one tail and a lot of you guys are
getting primed to see this anytime you
see conditional your mind goes baz do
you guys want to see what happens if we
just threw Baye at this wonderful
question if we threw Baye at this
wonderful question you get the
probability of this given that as your
first term so probability heads equals 9
and Tails equals 1 oh I missed a
given
given x = x times the probability that x
=
x divided
by some
constant and by some constant I mean
like okay this should actually be the
probability of heads equals 9 and Tails
equals 1 kind of marginalized over all
the values of X so integrate from 0 to 1
the probability of heads equals 9 tails
= 1 given x = x times the probability
that xal X and you're like oh that
sounds so awful but recall I'm even
though that's the real
expression I know that it's a constant
as you change the numerator this value
doesn't
change it doesn't solve all of our
problems and before I do anything um I
just want to leave you guys with this I
don't want you to talk to your partner
and trying to come up with an answer but
I want want you to talk to your partner
and try and come up with a good question
to ask them make sure this is a weird
statement what is that saying if it
helps try putting in a 0.5 in for little
X and saying what's the probability that
X takes on the value of 0.5 see if you
can come up with a good question see if
you can think about these three terms
and have a good conversation for just a
minute and then we're going to dive into
and we're going to solve this equation
on the board okay talk to the person
next to to have a nice little chat and
let's get into this
you don't have a blue marker do
you
yeah that's all I
mean
okay I have put a small mistake on this
board
but first I want to take some questions
maybe some of the questions will lead me
to have to think about that small
mistake is this weird or what x is a
random variable can I ask you guys some
questions what's the probability that X
is less than
zero yeah yeah your random variable that
represents probably can't be less than
zero What's the probity that X is
greater than one yeah can't be greater
than one okay that sounds very good um
is X discret or is it
continuous
it is continuous yeah we think about
probabilities as being able to take on
continuous values in which case there is
a small notation mistake I've made there
shouldn't be a probability instead it
should be a
density you know for continuous random
variables we want this other idea which
is a density and over here too our prior
belief also needs to be a
density this is not a density what does
this statement say it says I'm entering
the world where the TR true probability
of a heads is equal to Little X put in5
for x and says I'm entering the world
where the true probability of a heads
is5 in that world what's the probability
of getting nine heads in one tail that's
not a probability density that is a
straight
probability okay questions that came
up
okay you actually have the tools to
reason about this term
this prior though it's priors are hard
to just reason about from first
principles normally they're given to
you what is a reasonable belief before
you see any evidence so I've just given
you a brand new drug it could work 0% of
the time it could work 100% of the time
you have zero evidence what's a
reasonable prior belief for how well
this drug
works yeah uniform yeah uniform but are
there other choices so your prior belief
is uniform it's just as likely to be
between zero and one what about this
one you could say I believe it's 1 half
and I'm very confident it's one half I'm
really confident it's one half if you've
never seen this drug before which one do
you want do you want to say I'm pretty
sure it's one2 and I'm going with that
or do you want to say I have no
information and it's equally likely who
wants I'm pretty sure it's one half and
who wants I have no
information yeah that's the prior we
want before you see anything about your
drug you have to have a prior belief and
the best prior is if you've got no
information all probabilities look
equally
likely now you have enough information
for this part and that part by the way
you see this because this is equal to
this divide by constant do you guys know
that I can move this constant over here
I can just have like my one over the
constant
here I could just make this like one
over the constant and for those of guys
who are really fancy you can just write
is proportional to how fancy do I it's
like a little backwards
fish but that just means equals that
times a constant I'm getting a little
more fancy than I need
to
okay I said you guys could reason about
this term should we put in a value of 05
imagine a value of 05 in for a little X
it's saying what's the probability of
this given that that is the probability
of getting a heads if I tell you the
probability of heads and I ask you
what's the chance of getting nine heads
scream out what you want to do bom yeah
it's a binomial you've had 10 trials you
got nine successes and I've told you the
probability of success because we've
entered the world where this is the true
probability of success because I'm
conditioning off this you now know the
probability this is what a binomial
looks like in this notation and so we
can say this is proportional to the
binomial coefficient so you have 10
trials we have nine successes what's the
probability of success on each Tri
oo yeah it's a little X there it's not
p x is our random variable that's
representing P how many successes Did I
Get Nine how many failures did I get o
what's the probability of a failure 1 -
x how fancy and there's been one failure
this is just a binomial it says 10
experiments nine successes the
probability of success is
X now you're like but but X is a
variable here yeah and we're going to be
thinking about it for all possible
values we'll think about it for zero
we'll think about it for
0.252 75 for all values we'll be
thinking about this okay how about this
one this term over here seems
annoying it's our prior belief that X
takes on the value Little X again enter
the mindset that little X is 1/2 for now
what is the density of 1/2
well this is what we said our prior
was if Little X is zero what's this
value one if Little X is2 what's this
value how about 75 I'm not getting that
tricky am I no matter what you put in
for a little X it will come out as a one
so this whole term just becomes times
one and you're left with by the way this
is a constant you're left with the
density of x is proportional to x ^ 9 *
1 - x ^
1 do you guys want to know what that
looks like if you were to graph it it
looks like this your belief after you
see nine is still a random variable it's
just a random
variable oh wait I got that wrong it's
more confident than
that like if you were to plot that
equation that we just
derived it would look something like
this it's going to say I'm pretty sure
that the true probability is close to
0.9 but I have room for doubt I think
it's possible that the true probability
is one2 and then I just saw a really
unlucky set of heads and tails I think
it is very unlikely that true
probability is zero and it's possible
that the true probability is greater
than nine by making probability a random
variable I'm able to hold all this doubt
in my mind I'm able to express my belief
in all the possible assignments to the
probability
P if you followed along this hard set of
math that's the hardest thing for today
and the most important thing for today
and you'll understand the whole concept
of a beta distribution so let's take
some questions yeah so a question on our
assertion of the uniform distribution
repeat again why we know that every
value has to be one my intuition was
like okay if we are dividing every
single probility is equal as an
infinitely small number chance that each
probability can have okay so let's go uh
it's a good question so I want to pull
this one
up the uniform distribution it takes in
a Min and a Max and you put zero and one
the equation for the uniform
distribution says that it's its value at
all those is 1id your max minus your Min
and 1 divid 1 - 0 is just one so if we
have the uniforms from 0 to one this was
our prior belief and its density is one
everywhere does that kind of answer the
question and the reason is not like the
infinite this uniform is kind of doing
that infinite small Division and then
you know as you get into derivative
space nicely this just becomes a box
plot and the height of the box plot is
just your max minus your
minimum or one divided by that good
question cool more questions more
questions
yes if you had G like 10 heads and no
tails would that have changed the graph
to look more like parabolic so that mean
like there was like an upward trend for
the yes you're right so hold that
question because when I pull up the
graphs we're going to look at a whole
bunch of them and ask me again then but
you're right your in is correct yes like
still about like like variables like
usually like when you find of like
probability dity function it sums up to
one how it get in this if you integrate
under this box my claim is it integrates
to one if you integrate over here you're
going to get the area of this rectangle
right the width of the area a rectangle
is 1 minus 0 that's one and the height
of the rectangle is one so 1 * 1 is one
this integral is
one good
question
fantastic okay that's so we talked a lot
about this and then you guys seem to be
following Along on this idea of the
binomial very
nicely yes
yeah how got from
second from here to here um all that I
lost is I lost the minus *
one and then I also lost this thing but
that's because I thought it was a
constant so this proportional to it's
hiding that it's actually this but
there's a whole bunch of constants I've
multiplied everything by and if I want
to be explicit everything's multiplied
by 10 over choose 9 divided by you know
the denominator of bay theorem but I'm
going to call that
K uh and so if you want to make this an
equal sign it would look like this and
the proportional is just capturing the
fact that this is a constant it has
nothing to do with little
X okay such good
questions so if you flip a coin 10 times
I have just given you something much
more sophisticated to do than just
saying your probability is 9 over 10
I've allowed you to express your whole
probability belief in the coin being
heads the probability of a coin being
heads as a random variable this is the
deration we did you know this we've
identified as a binomial that we've
identified as the uniform if you just
plug in the uniform you get a one and
you're just left with the binomial and
then my claim is that this is the
normalization constant we've seen very
many times you could calculate it in
some ways or you could just find
whichever value allows this thing to
integrate to
one okay and here is the actual plot of
what that looks like I drew it by hand
but this is the actual plot of x to the
power of 9 * 1 - x^ of 1 if you were to
find the K that makes sure that this
integrates to
one cool right oh I love this plot I
find it so interesting um there's a
little bit of a philosophy here there's
a whole um world of probabilities that
think you're never allowed to have a
prior like there is a prior belief in
here they call themselves frequentists
but but a lot of people I know fall into
this Camp of beijan which is like if you
allow yourself to have this prior
there's such elegant mathematics that
can allow you to have a posterior so I
just want to bring that up a little bit
and we can talk more about that in
office hours if people find it
interesting Okay g to bump this up a
little
bit what if we had to solve
this but we didn't have uh exactly how
many many heads and tails there were but
instead we just said there was n heads
and M
Tails so this is the exact same
derivation that we did before but
instead of putting in numbers n and one
I'm going to allow them to be little n
for number of heads and little M for
number of tails you know why I want to
do that because you might want to do
this for numbers that are not N9 and one
you might want to see what happened if I
had six heads and three tails and you
like to be able to do the same sort of
mathematics so this is the exact same
derivation but we're going to put in
symbols for heads and symbols for number
of Tails make
sense and if you do that exact same
derivation you get the exact same thing
you get some constant times x to the
power of number of heads Time 1 - x to
the power of number of tails you look at
this equation over here you see the
similarity it's just we used a number
nine for heads and one for tails and
this is n for heads and M for
Tails okay
and this is a beautiful expression of a
random variable I note that there's a
constant here and if you wanted to find
that constant you could find whatever
number makes this equation integrate to
one which we've done before on problem
sets ah and this is it on one slide if
there was a major key if you've seen n
successes and M
failures you can say your new belief in
the prob ility of a success is given by
this gorgeous equation where if you ever
needed to find that constant you could
but it turns out often times you don't
actually need to find that
constant oh and this could have been how
they invented math and this could have
been how they defined things but it
turns out that people did things
slightly different which I'll get to in
a second I just want to make it clear
that you know if you want to do seven
heads and one tails you would just plug
in seven for n and one for number of
taals and you would plot it and you
would get some sort of beautiful
representation of your uncertainty is it
possible if you've seen seven heads and
one tails that the true probability is
0.
five it's not that likely but it's
certainly possible is it possible that
it's 08 oh yeah and it's starting to
look pretty likely but you know the most
likely one here is uh 7 /
unfortunately whoever invented this
mathematics did the cheekiest little
thing they did Define random variable
for this but they added a hidden plus
one just to mess up 109 students just to
make sure that there's always one extra
point on a midterm or final
problem people did Define this random
variables and they said I will tell you
the belief in your probability if you've
seen certain number of heads and certain
number of Tails but just to mess you up
the parameters won't be number of heads
and number of Tails no no that would be
too simple instead we'll make the
parameters number of heads plus one and
number of tails plus one just to make
sure everyone's always doing their plus
ones
correctly and so they defined a random
variable that looks exactly like what we
derived but you have to take number of
heads plus one and subtract off one and
you have to take number of tails plus
one and subtract off one what cheeky
buggers but they did it and we can't
fight it now it's much too late the
people who did this dve this thing
called a beta random variable it has
this probably density function it's what
we derived but the parameters are number
of heads plus one and number of tals
plus one so the probability density
function has to subtract off the ones to
make it the same derivation of what
we've got here is a bunch of different
betas here is a beta with one heads and
seven Tails notice how I myus one there
so cheeky this is a beta if you saw four
heads and four tails this is a beta if
you saw seven heads and one tail a
question there's a reason why one so do
you know why yeah some of the
mathematics that are a little bit beyond
like you get into like different moments
like some of those more complicated
things I think work out a little bit
nicer and we will see a couple of them
like expectation variance the equation
actually yeah let's let's pull those up
okay the expectation equation a little
bit cleaner the variance equation a
little bit cleaner and you can imagine
as you go deeper into the moments which
we don't do in CS 109 it the mathematics
makes it much easier to have the plus
one okay so when we use the beta varable
we should plug in
Not A and B but a plus one and B plus
one or number of heads add one that
becomes a you take your number of tails
you add one that becomes B it's like
life is hard enough when you're thinking
about probably as a random variable who
needs this plus one but I don't know
mathematicians in those days were cruel
not anymore now we're like warm and
fuzzy you're mathematicians too okay so
a bunch of betas and beta is the random
verif for probability and it's a
beautiful thing it has two parameters
you take your number of successes AKA
heads add one you take your number of
failures add one call those A and B and
then you just plug it in and now I want
to go back to this deep philosophical
idea now you have two ways of
representing a probability this is what
we did until today we would say your
probability is 75 and from now on I can
give you a probability not as a single
point estimate that's a fancy way of
saying a number but I can give it to you
as a whole random variable and that
whole random variable is going to do so
much work for us not only does it tell
you your most likely probability but it
also gives you a sense of how uncertain
you are about your probability it tells
you how confident I should be in this 75
there's no confidence expressed in this
number and by having expression of
confidence we're going to open up the
world of randomized algorithms and we're
have so many cool things that we'll be
able to do how fun is this are you guys
following along this is crazy
complicated stuff but it seems like like
you guys are following the plot which I
love to
hear um it's a distribution
probabilities I also want to point out
it's one of the few distributions that
we have that's bounded in a Min to Max
uniform and betas are the two random
variables we have that have a clear
minimum value and a clear maximum
value
okay I'm going to mess things up if you
follow the plot line till now you've
gotten the most heart of the matter but
I do want to give you the fancy details
on top you guys ready for
it we made a uniform decision for our
prior what if you used a beta itself as
a prior and what that means is somebody
comes up to you and they say like I got
this plate before you start flipping it
I have a belief I can look at its
physics and I can say I think it's more
likely to be a heads than a tail I
express that to you as a beta I express
that to you as a beta
32 so number of imagined heads was two
and imagined Tails was one 32 that's my
prior belief for you that's going to
mess up our math isn't it because now
instead of having a one here we have to
put in a beta probabbly density function
boogers and by Beta probab density
function I mean this beautiful equation
over here what happens so what's the
belief in x given n heads and there's an
implicit M Tails here as well so that's
the probability of You' seeing your n
heads within your experiments given the
true probability this is what we have up
there but now we're going to have a
different prior we're still going to
have the same binomial over here it's
just this is not going to be just a one
now your prior is a beta wild ready for
it just put in that whole beta probably
density function right there you're like
oh that's so
ugly well let's clean it up a little bit
why don't we get all the constants here
so that's a constant that oh actually
that is not a constant but um that's a
constant that's a
constant oh actually no sorry sorry this
is a constant so I'm going to take this
one this one and this one these are all
constants and I'm just going to put them
into one doesn't that look cleaner
already by constants I mean these values
don't change uh as you change X so if
you change X this stays the same if you
change X
this stays the same if you change X this
stays the same so we're going to put it
all over here and we say that can be a
number and it'll be whatever number it
needs to be so that this thing
integrates to one and we could stop out
of our cleanup here and be like ah we
did a nice job of clean up anybody see
way we can clean this up a little bit
better oh yeah we have X to ^ of n
multip x^ a minus one you can combine
those terms you can also combine the
term that has 1 - x as its base and if
you combine those terms you're left with
x^ of n n + a - 1 and 1 - x^ m + b - 1
and at this point you might feel super
good you're like so clean
legit and then the tears start
Welling because you see it you're like
this isn't as simple as it it gets
simpler it gets more beautiful because
if you were to stare at this for long
enough you might be like wait a second
that's really similar to the beta
probably Den function and then at some
point you're like wait a second that is
a beta probability density function just
with different parameters and then the
tears just happiness streaming from your
face as you
realize if your prior was a beta and
then you observe n heads and M Tails
your belief after that information is
another
beta so anyways there is a fancy term
for this we call called it a conjugate
prior it's like your belief in your
random variable takes a part particular
form in this case of beta before you get
some evidence and then afterwards you
get to use the same equation format if
your belief before you see evidence is a
beta your belief afterwards will also be
a beta and that makes programming much
easier because you know if you're
getting new information you don't have
to write new equations you just have to
update parameters so this is saying you
had a prior belief in A and B I saw a
real number of heads and real number of
tals and afterwards I can just update my
parameters that's all I need to do
because we've done this math once you
can be left with the idea that if your
prior was a beta your posterior your
belief after seeeing evidence is also a
beta where you just add in the number of
observed heads and the number of
observed
Tails I talk fast so like I just said a
big thing maybe I should just like let
that sit like whoa
cool ah
okay uh what does this really mean if
you didn't want to drive the mathematics
you'd say that you can set your belief
uh as a prior using a beta so before you
do your experiment you can say I'm going
to say I think that this isn't uniform
before you start flipping I'd say it's
more likely to be heads I have a way
expressing that and then if you did that
you said I'm going to imagine a fake
heads and B fake tails before you start
flipping
if you then see n or sorry A minus one
fake heads B minus one fake tails see I
even forgot Theus one plus one if you
then flip this and you see n heads and M
Tails your posterior is just a beta as
well beautiful
thing there is one thing you need to
know most people don't always use
uniform as a prior belief you know it's
a different prior belief that a fellow
called llas made very popular he said my
prior belief
is one imagined head and one imagined
tail and there's a deep philosop
philosophy that he went into he's
talking about the probability of the sun
rising and he says even though I've seen
the sunrise every single day and I
believe it will likely happen tomorrow I
want to imagine at least one failure and
one success so I can hold in my mind
some belief that it might not happen in
the future long story short having a
beta 2 is a popular choice for prior
uniform is popular beta 22 is
popular okay funny name simple prior
okay then one last thing before we start
playing
games I want to just show you a cool
derivation what if you asked what
happens of a is one and B is one
remember a is your number of heads plus
one and B is your number of tails plus
one so if you take one and you subtract
off one what are you left
with so this is say saying beta with
zero heads and zero
Tails oh so you write out your probably
density function you put in your value
of number of heads you get your number
of Tails and this is a number to zero
that's one and this is a number to zero
that's also one and so you end up with
this 1 * 1 divid by whatever constant
makes this integrate to one and you're
left with one you know at a beta with
AAL 1 Bal 1 is it's
uniform and that makes sense if you've
seen zero heads and z tals your belief
is uniform it's just the prior because
you saw no information anyways that's
not that deep but you know nice little
rounding of the
corner
okay we are going to flip some
plates okay I'm going to now show you
guys the nice part of the course reader
where you can look at a beta so I'm
going to start flipping this plate and
before I flip this plate my belief in
the probability of heads is that it's
uniform beta 1 one I've seen zero heads
I've seen zero tails are you guys ready
for me to flip a plate okay close
ears Tails okay a is number of heads
plus one I've now seen a
tails look at that belief is it possible
to be one probability of a heads no
because we just saw a Tails but it's
this beautiful straight
line is there a problem because this y-
axis is two like it goes all the way up
to
two not a problem probably densities are
allowed to be outside one if you
integrate under this for any range
you'll get a probability flip it again
close ears o i saw heads so now I've
seen one head and one tail and this is
my new belief it can't be zero
probability it can't be one it's much
more likely to be 50/50 than anything
else but I have a belief now I'm going
to flip it one more times but then I'm
going to think about how we could update
this I saw myself another heads two ways
you could update this you could say I've
seen two heads and one tails and make my
Beta or you could say this was my prior
belief and I've just observed one heads
and zero tails and because of this
conjugate prior thing they lead to the
exact same result it is still the case
I've seen three heads and one tails and
look at that beta change I love it do
you want to just like come up here and
flip a
couple wonderful head yeah flip and then
I'll update it
yay he does so much for us we really
appreciate you and all the head ta teams
okay flip let's
go oh another heads I in fact think that
this thing does have higher probability
of heads that's why I chose three I was
trying to set you up
okay
o another one yeah let's keep flipping
one more let's do one more for good for
good
nature ooh it Tails okay so in total how
many times do we flip it we flipped it
four five six times we saw four heads we
saw two taals unfortunately we have to
add one to each of those to get the beta
parameters and then you get this
probability distribution we have a
belief it's beautiful you can ask
expectation question you can talk about
variance you can ask what's the
probability that the true probability is
between 05 and 0.9 by integrating you
can ask all these questions just like
with any other random variable you guys
are wonderful fall on the plot and
that's just all I have to
say Okay
so I also just want to show you a word
problem that I think is
interesting before being tested a pill
is believed to work about 80% of the
time then we do a real trial on 20
people in this real trial it works for
14 people and it doesn't work for six
what is your no belief that the drug
works this is a problem that you could
approach in a few ways before today in
CS 109 this is all you could do you
could say I don't know how to
incorporate that
80% but I do know how to talk about 14
out of 20 patients being successful with
the drug and that gives me a point
estimate for
probability but now you can come up with
a
beta the only thing is it doesn't give
you a prior in a format we've talked
about the prior is just saying
80% and can I give you three different
priors that match that
claim here's one prior that matches
80% I imagine 100 trials 80 of which
were successful here's a different PR
prior I imagine 10 Trials of which eight
are successful and here's a different
prior I imagine uh six trials sorry five
Trials of which four are successful all
of these are ways of representing 80%
but what's the difference this is very
confident this is medium confidence and
this is minimal
confidence and you'd have to make a
choice you'd have to say do they mean
80% and I really should trust them or do
they mean 80% and I want to trust them
just a little bit and the less you trust
them the more the data will dominate
your your belief and sorry the higher
these par
the less the data will dominate and the
lower these parameters the more the
actual observed data will dominate so in
this question 80% needs to be translated
into a prior three good choices actually
there's no wrong answer who wants this
one who wants this one and who wants
this one they're all right answers I
tend to like priors that are a little
bit less assuming I like to have my data
speak for itself as much as possible but
it really depends how much I trust these
people people whoever tells me 80% like
if it's will I'm going with the first
prior like whatever you say I'm going
with it but you know if it's somebody
who I don't know really well that's the
prior I'm going
with you can see why there's a division
some people in probability Theory are
like what you can't be so subjective
anyways so if you chose your prior we
now have a way of representing an 80%
belief then what's your posterior you
don't have to go all the way to Bay
theorem you could and if you did go all
the way to Bay theorem you would end up
deriving this you would end up deriving
that your posterior was your prior
parameter plus number of observed heads
and your prior parameter for number of
tals plus observed tales and you would
just add those in and an interesting
thing if you plot out this prior and you
plot out your posterior they both tell
similar stories but you've become more
confident as you saw more
information you can also talk about the
expected value you can say hey this is a
whole random variable but maybe I just
want to give one number for probability
and you can do that you can say what's
the expectation of this random variable
and you could
say7 now I want to point out a really
weird thing about the
beta expectation is a way of taking a
beautiful random variable and collapsing
it into one value it makes me sad
because you've lost so much information
there's a different way of taking a
whole beautiful random variable and
collapsing into one number called the
mode and they're different things
expectation is like your weighted
average the mode is whichever value has
the highest
probability whoa those are two different
things so the mode is the highest point
whichever x value has the highest point
in the PDF and the expectation is just
your weighted average of your PDF often
they were the same in almost all cases
we've seen before they've been the same
but in this case they're actually
different the mode is actually number of
heads divided by number of heads plus
tails and uh so if you did your mode and
your mean they're slightly different but
if there is one thing you took away from
this is that single numbers are boring
ways of representing probabilities and
distributions are so much richer they
capture so much more than single
numbers questions comments concerns does
the universe change no but your
understanding of it
does okay so next question for you guys
which video are you more likely to
like so now that you know about betas we
can think about these as coin flips this
is a coin that's been flipped 10,50
times and this is a coin that's been
flipped 10
times we could just think about the
probabilities as frequentist or we can
think about the probabilities with beta
distributions and if you thought about
the probabilities with beta
distributions this case I'm using that
fancy LL prior so I imagine one heads
and I imagine one
Tails this one look at this beta
distribution what's happened it's just
like a straight
line if you see enough evidence
eventually the beta distribution just
looks like a straight line at the true
probability so this one we know it's
like a
99.9 video but this one we haven't seen
that much information so we have to hold
out the belief it's a 6 video or the
belief that is a08 video and so there's
a whole distribution there's a
representation of uncertainty now if you
want to choose a video
that's a cool algorithm wouldn't you
like to know an algorithm for choosing
this video
now at the moment what have I told you I
a way told you how you can represent
your knowledge in a more beautiful
way but I haven't told you how to
compare this beta with that
beta
now what if you guys had to invent that
what if you had to invent a way to
decide if this video is better than that
one you can say
what's the probability that I'll like
this that what's which video has a
greater probability of that I like it
wait for each video I can calculate
what's the How likely is it that my
probability of liking is greater than
0.9 so I could say this one you know
it's 100% that I'll my chance of liking
is point greater than 0. n and here I
can say it's not 100% that my chance of
liking is greater than 0.9 it's just
whatever is under this
curve
okay I have one last beautiful thing for
you guys I'm done with the beta I'm not
done with the beta I'm done setting the
foundation of the beta I'm start ready
to start playing I'm ready to now use
the beta to do cool things but before I
do that if you guys have any other beta
questions shall we can I ask please yeah
yeah yeah that's all I do you remember
my experiment on like uh the believe
that the child is not being born today
um Can can you use that to the beta to
solve that like say you had a believe of
18 days um and then by day night the
child has not been
B I was just thinking the cont
of you're really on to something can I
hold my very last slide is talking about
this connection but you're on to
something which is in that world we were
thinking about a random variable as this
underlying belief which could take on
many values and the beta is going to
start making us do that in lots of cases
so yes you're that is the same mindset
in both those
problems and could we have multiple Bas
in such a way that places have your
emphasis on the more recent ones I guess
um whoa like a recency bias yeah you
just invented a new random variable
congratulations you can name it after me
no I'm just joking you can name it after
yourself you actually can't name after
yourself someone else has to name after
you I'll name it after you no I'm just
joking um uh that's a really nice idea
and why would you want to do that though
is that because you assume that the
probability might be
changing
potentially there's some situations
where that's the case hey flipping this
plate the probability is not going to
change there's no reason that one old
experiment is less valuable than a new
experiment but other things could change
like the probability of a hurricane that
might be a moving distribution and what
I would encourage you to do if you want
to go down the path of inventing this
random variable is just try formalizing
how you think like this particular
problem you're solving my probability is
changing can I make an assumption about
how it's changing and that will lead to
a different sort of random variable over
your belief and
probability in fact you'll probably have
a model
OKAY fantastic you guys are asking good
questions have you guys heard about
Alpha go they were the algorithm when
humans really for the first time um
well one at this board game called go
and if you don't know this board game
called go it's this huge board game was
thought to be the most complicated board
games that humans play and you really
need intuition to be able to win at this
game um and then this group called Deep
n which is one of the big AI Labs not
too long ago came with an algorithm that
could win at the world's most
complicated board game an interesting
thing that they did is they they did mix
deep learning but they also mixed deep
learning with core reasoning about
probabilities and really the sort of
beta distribution idea that we've been
talking about now there's this whole
world called multi arm Bandits and it's
a really fancy name for something that's
kind of simple to describe a multi-arm
bandit I think is best described using
this
scenario you have two different drugs
drug a and Drug B and you need to be
administering them to patients and you
don't know how well they both work and
as you're administrating you're doing
two things simultaneously you're giving
drugs and you're learning about the
drugs and that's what a multi-arm bandit
is this is arm one this is arm two the
Bandit makes it sound ridiculous um you
could have more than two drugs like
maybe there's six drugs you're choosing
between and every time a patient comes
you have to choose
one and you're both doing it to explore
which one's the best and to take
advantage of what you've already learned
so far isn't that an interesting problem
do you guys want to play okay I need
another volunteer to come up and play uh
you're going to or actually you know
what you're all going to play
I'm going to pull up this
game and the way this game works
is there's two drugs and we have to make
decisions and just to add the stakes I'm
going to assume that these drugs are for
uh let's just say they're for Pokemon so
we don't have to think about anything
grim and your Pokemon are going to live
or
die let me just open a new terminal so
it's cleaner python can you guys see
this okay in the back
there's two drugs your first patient
Walks In A or B you're like what I don't
know what's the prob of A and B that's
the beauty of this you don't know you
have to make a choice you're like this
is an awful awful game already Okay who
wants a who wants B just
yell I heard a lot of
B's we did it yay fantastic our Pokemon
lives and then another person comes a or
b a a
why do you want a obviously B worked a
is a better grade
yeah why would you want a why you have
just
curious curious no curious is right um
you know there's a possib we should be
learning about our drugs as well I'm
doing
B oh I immediately regret it okay your
curiosity was good but it was possible
that a was perfect but now I've tried B
twice it worked once and it failed again
who wants a and who wants B now just
yell a everyone wants a and the
intuition is yeah I have more
information about B but I haven't
explored a at all it might be way better
and I play a yes and now who wants a or
b a fantastic oh a or b
b a b b b oh my God I'm out of control
I'm just making decisions without any
sort of reasoning do a bunch of A's in a
row yeah you could do a bunch of A's in
a row you can do a bunch of B's in a row
and then you can go back and like try
and estimate and make better decisions
from here on out there's so many
contexts where this game is important
and it's not just about drugs there's
lots of things like um if you're trying
to learn how to make decisions under
uncertainty even if it's something small
like you're trying to give somebody a
nudge on dualingo and you're trying to
decide if you give a nudge or not it's
this game this game exists in so many
sorry A nudge is like hey hey have you
studied Spanish lately you know they do
that they have this whole paper where
they use this algorithm I'm just about
to teach
you so this game we just played it is
there a principled way of playing this
game and people have done a lot of
research on this and it's still out for
debate there's different people who have
different ideas of how you could play
this I'm going to set up a particular
context you've tried B five times you've
tried um oh sorry if you've tried B five
times and we got two successes and three
failures we have a formal way of
thinking about the probability that b is
successful uh and you can talk about
expectations we can talk about the
probability that the true probability is
greater than some
number and actually I just want to talk
about this one for a second just to get
us warmed up to this
problem if x is a beta because I've seen
I tried drug B five times I got two
successes um and I got three failures I
can set up the beta you're like why
three and four oh right I have to add
one to success and
failures what happens if I ask you
what's the probability that the true p
is greater than
6 well then that's asking the
probability that my random variable is
greater than 6 which we know is one
minus the probability that the random
variable is less than6 which means you
can do one minus the CDF of the beta and
then you're just like oh hey I don't
remember what the CDF of the beta is you
go over at your favorite course reader
and you're like there's the PDF and
there's a hey
if you look at our other continuous
random variables they often have this
thing called a CDF that's probably
random variable is less than a value and
the beta doesn't have a closed
form a little bit like the normal
distribution is the game over no the
game's not over we just have numerical
approximators so you know if I need the
beta CDF I don't use an equation I go to
Python and python has a numerical way of
telling me the CDF of a beta so anyways
you could do one minus you know stats.
beta. CDF you put in 6 for x and you put
in your two parameters and you'll get a
number back okay few so even though
there's no closed form for the CDF I do
want to point out that we just use
Python which uses a numerical
approximator
okay which leaves us with this game we
call it I mean it's got this awful name
it's called the exploration exploitation
trade-off that's that's this multiarm
Bandit where you're trying to choose
between a and b and and philosophically
you're choosing between going to the
place that you've been to the most and
you know have the most information or
going and learning more about one of
your different arms or drugs if you're
using that
metaphor there's as I said this is not a
closed problem there's still different
people debating on how you could solve
this drug problem one algorithm is this
thing called upper confidence bounds
which is for each drug you keep a
probably distribution over its success
and then you think about like an upper
bound of confidence you set some
threshold maybe like a standard
deviation or two standard deviations and
you try and choose uh drugs that have
the higher upper confidence that's one
way of doing it but then somebody not
too long ago wrote a paper that pulled
on some math from a little while ago and
said wait a second there's this other
algorithm that works insanely well for
ch using drug a or drug B here's how it
goes you've been playing the game for a
while where you can have drug a and you
can have drug B why do my a and Bs look
like graphs because we're using betas
you know I did number of successes
number of failures I got the beta CDF
and if you plot them you get these two
things so it's like drug B we've tried
more drug a looks a little bit better
but we haven't tried it as
much so that's the state of the game
how do you choose which drug to play
next and somebody not too long ago came
up with this wicked simple
idea take drug A's PDF and sample from
it you're more likely to get a number in
the high density regions and less likely
to get a number in the low density
regions so let's do this let's say you
randomly sample and you get this
value and that's going to be my a
sample for B you sample from B and you
may just happen to choose a sample over
here it's not that likely but when you
sample you can get any value it's just
more likely to get them in the high
probability regions you know if you do a
gaan samples you're more likely to get
something near the mean if you do a
sample from this beta you're more likely
to get something in the high probability
regions so Step One is choose a sample
from each drugs beta so here I got a and
that was like equal to
5.58 that's my sample for drug a a and
my sample for drug B was equal to
42 here's the crazy thing we're halfway
through an algorithm the next step in
the
algorithm you know which drug we choose
not the one that has the higher area
under the curve at any point just
whichever one had the higher sample and
they would say you choose drug a
here when you're making a choice
you take your betas you sample from them
and you select the drug with the higher
sample and the argument was this does
two different
things it balances the fact that if
you're really confident drug is good
you'll always sample from that high
probability and if you're really
confident is better you'll just always
make the right choice but when you're
unconfident it does a beautiful balance
of exploring and taking advantage of
which one it already thinks is better
people are arguing that this is in some
context the best algorithm but there
could be better ones you could invent
one in fact there's a one9 student last
quarter I taught this who said if you
always choose a drug such that if the
probability of drug a beta is greater
than the probability of
B I choose
a and the probability of B is greater
than a I choose B and they they figure
out this inequality and then that's how
they made their choice they claimed to
me that this is better than Thompson
sampling I was like o that's kind of
cool um and maybe they're right what I
will tell you is you guys get to play so
if you look at problem set
4 The Last Problem on problem set four
is to play exactly this game you're
going to write a function you'll get a
history of all the drugs that have been
given and whether or not they worked and
then you have to return either A or B
and when when you run one game here I'm
always choosing a and you'll get a score
of how well you did if you run test
agent you'll get a score over multiple
trials I want you guys to implement this
Thompson sampling which will be pretty
easy now that you know what a beta is
but feel free to try and come up with a
better algorithm if you feel so
fit okay so can I summarize today you
learned about beta a beautiful way of
representing probabilities and then we
used it for a new randomized algorithm
it's the distribution for probabilities
it's got this beautiful formula it's
actually the very last distribution I I
plan to talk about and so you can
imagine it is a new distribution to add
to our whole pile of distributions we
have so far if there's one philosophy
that I really wanted to drive home it's
that in life we often convolve things
into a single
number but it's so much more elegant if
you can keep a whole random variable
which has a whole belief distribution
because then you're able to represent
your uncertainty and if you can
represent your uncertainty you can do
things like Thompson sampling you can
make better decisions under uncertainty
if you can represent what you don't know
I feel like this doesn't represent what
it doesn't know but the beta really
does we talked about this at the
beginning of class and that confidence
and a probability is something we've now
gained with the ability to articulate
beta so somebody says like my leg itches
when it rains they're probably 08 that's
close to a uniform you like that sounds
like a pretty useless uh probability but
this one we could have a formal way of
talking about the beta distribution that
it comes from and we can say that that
second one is more confident and we have
language for
that and then I want to leave you with
this other
idea we talked about using
probability as a random variable a
probability you can think of as the
parameter to a binomial it's like the
parameter to this binomial what was the
thing that was unknown that we allowed
to be a random variable and you can do
this for any parameter for example a pan
you could say I don't know the true rate
and I would like to estimate the true
rate and you can say what's the belief
distribution in the true rate given that
observed sum history and maybe that's
the more interesting thing and you can
talk about if you're like taking an eye
disease like we did in section a while
ago and you see some count of
cells instead of just saying I think
this is pan you can allow for it's a pan
and I've only seen five cells I don't
know what the true average is and by
having a softer belief if somebody asks
you did this person get better or worse
you could make a better decision about
that and so my bigger point is you could
take any parameter and allow it to be a
random
variable and that will be a more elegant
way of expressing it and that was
related I think to the question about
baby births before which is that really
taking all these Concepts and making
them random variables will give you much
more powerful ways to talk about
likelihoods
thank you guys so much if you're taking
exam tonight good luck if you're not
taking exam tonight definitely don't
talk to anyone about the exam you took
uh have a wonderful wonderful day come
back on Friday we'll continue this great
topic in cs19 I'm rooting for all of you
guys I'm thinking about you often have a
wonderful
day